We've had written history for 5,000
years.
People have been generally literate for
less than 500 years,
but we've had culture for 150,000 years
identifiable culture for at least 25,000
so the vast period of our enculturation
was preliterate in culturation before we
could write down the rules and transmit
them.
How were they transmitted?
Assuming we had culture?
Well,
there's a variety of mechanisms.
We have a tendency to see elements of
the world in personified form because
most of the interrelationships we have
with the world are actually social or
interpersonal relationships.
So that's basically how our brain is
structured.
And as we evolved,
we develop the capacity to extend our
cognitive ability beyond the merely
social to take in the world as such.
But the categories that we use to do
that,
we're still fundamentally social.
Now.
The reason the unknown per se is
symbolized his feminine is because the
critical feature of the feminine,
and I don't mean the female individual,
I mean the feminine as a category is its
capacity to generate new forms.
And the unknown is such as as logically
and appropriately symbolized by the
feminine because it's the bringer.
Fourth of all things,
which is to say that the background of
existence,
the unknowable background of existence
is the thing that generates everything
paired with that,
of course,
according to the Schema that we've been
working with,
uh,
is the archetype of the great father.
And the archetype of the great father is
the archetype of tradition.
Fundamentally the great weight of the
past.
Because as you incorporate your past,
the past of your culture,
through the intermediation of your
parents,
you learn routines and rituals for
structuring the unknown.
Now those are routines and rituals are
patterns of action that you use in the
world as such.
And also complex patterns of action that
you use to structure your own
interpretations and your own motor
output and your own conceptualizations
when you're dealing with other people.
And so that would be the absorption fund
most fundamentally of your cultural
rules and the fact of those cultural
rules and their incarnation in you
essentially keeps chaos at bay.
Which means if two of you share the same
cultural structure,
assuming you're playing the same game,
so to speak,
that means that you can each predict
each responses,
which is very,
very useful because that way you,
you can be sure that you can trust the
other person.
You can more or less in further goals
because after all,
their value structure of similar to
yours and if you can infer their goals,
that means you can embody their
emotions.
So that's the benevolent aspect of
tradition,
right?
The part that protects and shelters you
instructors,
the nature of your being in the face of,
of existential terror and doubts,
so to speak,
but there's also an aspect of tradition
that's terrible,
a tyrannical,
it's the part that marches young men off
towards say in defense of the structures
that it's protecting.
It's the part that says,
when you're a teenager where this and
not this,
or you'll be the target of mockery for
all your peers.
It's the part of the structure that
crushes the creative life out of you
because the tyrannical aspect of social
order doesn't want your creative light
life,
so to speak.
What it wants is your obedience because
you're a bds is what makes the machine
run smooth.
And so you're always in an ambivalent
relationship with regards to security to
authority.
On the one hand it provides you shelter
and what you need and allows you to gain
the benefits of literally thousands and
thousands of years of cultural
evolution.
On the other hand,
it's the thing that makes you obey or
face the painful consequences thereof,
which can range from,
you know,
mere social exclusion and consequent
re-exposure to the unknown,
to,
to truly oppressive practices designed
to make you be exactly like everyone
else or else.
And so you could say most particularly
again,
that that's a standard existential
problem.
It's a problem that's faced by people in
every place,
in every culture,
balancing the appropriate attitude
towards culture.
So the most fundamental representation
of culture can be portrayed essentially
in this manner,
I think.
And uh,
what you see here is the dragon of
chaos,
of course,
lurking in the background.
And what that means is that all forms
come from the formless and that the
farther itself is a primary form,
a representation of God.
The father and God,
the father in the Christian Trinity is
the representation of the positive end,
the security inducing,
and the tyrannical aspect of social
order,
right?
God has a set of rules for you.
You bloody well better listen to those
rules if you don't all hell's gonna
break loose.
And you know,
that's a pretty reasonable summary of
how things work unfortunately.
So on the one hand God offers security.
On the other hand,
he offers tyranny and in total that
basically represents orders.
So you can see this representation is
quite useful.
Chose God's standing over this city,
which of course is a city,
uh,
committed to him fundamentally.
So it operates under the moral
principles that he represents.
And behind him is a representation of
the sun,
which is partly a representation of the
source of all life,
partly a representation of the source of
consciousness and illumination,
right?
Cause you're conscious during the day
and partly,
uh,
Halo representing the sort of
transcendent nature of the,
of the social order that structure,
structures existence.
So it's a primary phenomenon and it's
only to say that in all human experience
there's a cultural aspect and a natural
aspect and the funny thing is the
cultural aspect.
In some ways this as natural as the
natural aspect,
right?
Because we're social beings,
we can't exist without society.
Society structures are very nature.
Ben and were beneficiaries and victims
and so then just as the case just as is
the case with the
feminine,
there's a two aspects that can be
represented metaphorically with regards
to the masculine.
You can say,
well,
the security aspect of social order is
the wise king and you could see medieval
representation of a mirror sitting on
his throne calmly in a relatively open
posture.
That means he's ready to listen to sub
to supplicants to people who are coming
to talk to him.
He's holding an orb with a cross on top
of it,
which means essentially that he's in
control of the world and the world is
subordinated to something else that's
represented by the cross,
a wise and just ruler and then his
mirror image here is the sun devouring
king.
A very common mythological theme.
The father who wants to destroy his son.
And there's shades of the eatable
conflict in that of course,
if you remember your Freud.
But basically what it means is this,
is that despite the fact that every
human being is an offspring of culture
by nature,
um,
every human being is also in the
terrible position of facing the fact
that they're very individuality is
likely to be crushed out of them during,
during the socialization process.
And that in a sense,
that's really not an,
that's really not avoidable.
I mean,
if you're subject to really tear radical
socialization,
it's obviously a much more cardinal
problem,
right?
But even if you're subject to
socialization under normal
circumstances,
you are still what you are rather than
the manifold things that you could have
otherwise been.
And,
and,
and just to give you some sense of how
dramatic a process this really is,
one of the things you should know is
that you actually die into your brain.
So one of the things you might wonder
is,
why is,
why is it the death evolved?
It,
it doesn't really make that much sense
from a Darwinian perspective,
right?
Because you'd make the presupposition
that if you could just stick around and
farther children safe for 250 years,
you'd be doing a lot better job than the
poor sap who only live to be 30 so why
is it that you only live to be 70 and
really your,
you know,
your period of fertility is say by the
time you're 40 why would that be?
What's the utility of death?
And then you remember,
well the environment's always changing,
right?
In this chaotic manner that's
represented the great mother,
can you change with it?
And the answer to that is yes,
but only to a certain point,
which is why as people age,
they stay tend to become more and more
alienated from the current culture,
right?
They've,
they've adopted their position of being
say,
which is a word more or less fixed by
the time they're 25 or so.
Once their prefrontal cortex matures and
then after that the world gets away
from,
they don't have enough biological
resources left to constantly undergo new
revolutionary neurological processes.
And part of the reason is this,
you have more neural connections in your
brain.
When you're first born,
then you do for the rest of your life
any other time in your life.
And as you learn when you're an infant
and as you learn,
say over the first two years,
what happens is that there's a
plentitude of circuits and they die off
leaving only those circuits that have a
function.
And you think about that,
it's kind of a quasi Darwinian process.
And so what that means is that as you
mature and become fixed in your form,
you know,
to adopt your personality,
whatever it becomes,
what's happening is that the excess
possibility in some sense is being
demolished by experience.
So the [inaudible] aspect of
enculturation is something that's real
because it makes you in large part what
you are.
And you have to understand as well that
that's necessary because it's better to
be something in the final analysis.
It's better to be something than to be
nothing.
But you know,
we still have residual dreams like those
expressed by Peter Pan,
say who's the boy that never wants to
grow up because he doesn't want to
attain any final and fixed form.
And it's interesting because in one
respect,
as you progress through your life,
you're climbing,
assuming things are going well,
you're climbing to ever new heights.
But on the other hand,
the,
the direction that you're going in
constantly narrows as you age.
So there's a real trade off there.
And,
and,
and I think the existential angst that's
caused as a consequence of that trade
off is often real.
And I also think that adolescents in
early adults feel this most intently,
which is part of the reason why they
tend to rebel against social structures
in general.
You know,
the,
whether it's the military industrial
complex or the corporate world or
globalization or what have you,
is that you have these large structures
that represent the tier radical aspect
of social being.
And,
and it's no wonder that the fact of
those structures in genders rebellion,
it should.
On the other hand,
it's also no wonder that structures like
that exist.
Because if they didn't exist,
then people would have no way of
interrelating there,
their social being.
And we would revert back to the sort of
hobbsy and state of war where
everybody's arms are around.
Everybody else's throat.
That doesn't mean the payoff is always
good.
So for the Floridians,
of course,
had a real field day with this,
and,
and we're,
we're most fundamentally concerned by
it.
Now,
part of the reason that Friday and
psychology,
he's had such an immense impact on
western and world cultures because Freud
came along just when classical,
Judeo Christian mythological structures
were on the,
on a serious decline in the west.
And Freud stepped in with a secularized,
mythological version version of reality,
which said,
well,
there's nature knocks the Ed,
right?
That's the wild and untamed impulses
that spring up from,
from the animal mind.
And there's the ego,
which is the individual who's,
who's in many ways a pawn of these ed
like forces.
And then on top of the ego,
crushing it down into the Ed,
so to speak,
is the Superego,
which is the,
uh,
internal and external embodiment of
social order and morality.
So you can see the mythological
substructure underlying Freud.
Freud said,
well,
the ego is always being shaped by the
superego.
And it's always compulsion.
It's don't,
don't,
it's always,
no,
it's like Old Testament morality.
Right?
And the incarnation of the 10
Commandments,
whatever you want to do.
If it feels good,
the probability is high,
that it's immoral from the perspective
of the social world.
And you can really see this with
children.
You know,
it's really remarkable to watch them
because my sense is,
and I don't think this is just because
I'm a particularly tyrannical farther,
is that children often get in more
trouble for having fun and they do for
any other reason because their capacity
for unbridled enjoyment is so unbridled
that it actually poses a threat to
orderly structure.
So you know,
if a child really gets into inactive
mood and is playing a very active game,
I mean,
especially if they're are somewhere
between say three and five,
they can tear your house to shreds and
no times,
no time flat.
And you're always following them around
going,
no,
quiet down.
Don't do that.
And you know,
they're smiling away and they're happier
than any adult you're ever going to see
in your entire life.
And you're doing everything you can to
push them down so that they can sit
quietly and read a book or whatever it
is you think they should be doing.
And that's really nasty and horrible.
But by the same token,
it's absolutely necessary because if
they don't learn to bring their
impulses,
even their impulses,
they're ludic impulses,
right?
Their impulses to play under control,
then nobody else can stand them.
And if they don't get access to the
resources that are in the social world,
man,
they have one dismal life laid out in
front of them.
So anyway,
so that's an early description of the
genesis of the conflict,
say between the ego and the superego.
And I just wanted to point that out
because it's not just sex and aggression
that gets regulated,
right?
I mean,
we can understand why that might happen,
but it's also playfulness and creativity
and spontaneity and all the things that
we associated with the joy of being that
the terrible tyrannical social structure
puts a clamp on.
So Jaak Panksepp for example,
has recently demonstrated that children,
boys,
because it's usually boys who have
attention deficit disorder,
which is generally diagnosed in the
schoolroom,
do much better if they're placed on
methylphenidate,
which is a kind of a amphetamine
fundamentally.
But normal kids do better on
amphetamines too.
By the way.
They can focus better,
they can focus more and they can pay
attention more.
Mostly what methylphenidate does is
suppress play.
So panksepp's notion is that,
well,
what's happening with these adhd kids,
hyperactive kids,
is they're more playful,
more,
more boisterously playful,
which is tends to be a masculine
attribute.
And in the juvenile forms of many
mammals,
they're boisterously playful,
give them a little meth methylphenidate
that shuts down their play behavior and
they can sit down and focus,
you know,
and well,
you can understand how,
even if you might think that's necessary
because apparently many people do.
You can also still understand that by
the same token,
that probably represents some kind of
loss,
right?
Because we like to see kids play and
it's good for them besides,
so anyways,
Freud says the ego pops up.
It's all thrilled to death with the
world.
The superego comes along and shuts it
down and now it's a faith that befalls
all of us.
And not only that because Freud's a
pretty wise man,
all things considered,
he doesn't say that's a whole to the
bad.
He says that's the price we pay for
social being.
And Fair enough,
you see this happening in children all
the time where part of what they do as
they mature as to adopt rules so they'll
play being a father or being a mother
say and what they're doing is pulling in
what they see as as the world view that
characterizes parenthood,
embodying the farther,
playing out the role and trying to
organize their motivational structures
within the observed framework say that
the father provides and that's an
introjection of social wisdom.
If you can imagine that the role of
fathers say has a structure,
like one structure would be,
well if you're a father and you're
around to model,
then you have to be taken care of the
children.
Or at least you have to be there often
enough so that you can be a target of
modeling.
And so you can imagine that the spirit
of the father that's modeled,
at least in the optimal circumstances is
one that deals out rules in order,
but that also provides nurturing care
and support.
And that's a kind of story.
We know fathers who aren't like that and
maybe we know fathers who are too much
like that,
but all things considered on the
average,
you have a father role and children
attempt to interject that and that's
part of the way that they learn to
modulate their own motivation and
resources.
So for example,
if the child observes the father and the
mother sharing,
which means taking each other's
motivational states into account,
then they can act out the game of
sharing with a doll,
say representing a child.
And what they're doing is trying to
imagine what it's like inside that
doll's head.
Treating it like a person by embodying
the potential motivations and emotional
states of that pretend to object in
their own body.
And then by trying to organize a higher
order structure,
which would be like the tea party where
Tia shared a higher order structure
where you have a turn because you want
to turn because you're thirsty like me
and then I have a turn and we both get
what we want and we can exchange
information.
Well that's a little bit more optimistic
of the tyranny of social order than pure
compulsion.
Right?
Because what it suggests is there's a
way that you can organize the way you
are genuinely and the way I am genuinely
so that we both are genuine yet we get
something more than we would get if we
were just by ourselves.
And so you think that with kids they
like to play by themselves but by the
time they were about three and a half or
four boy,
like they have a hunger for other
children and they will do anything in
order to go out and play with other
kids.
So you can say to them,
well if you,
if you take all the toys off your bed,
I'll go let you play with your friend.
And like the toys are off there in two
tenths of a second and they're out the
door because they have this primary need
to go out and experiment with the social
world and in large way in large part,
that's how they build the complex higher
order,
more abstract structures that enabled
them to regulate their motivated.
They're motivational states and their
emotional states without just,
no,
it's,
it's a more sophisticated way of doing
it,
right?
It's better to play a game with someone
then to engage in a battle of wills with
them because then there's no compulsion.
There's just mutual participation.
And that's critical because one of the
things that the notion of the tyranny of
the social order brings up as a question
is,
all right,
so you have to take part in society,
right?
You have take your part in the social
world,
yet the social world wants it's pound of
flesh or it's 60 pounds of flesh
depending on where you live on the one.
So you're damned if you do so to speak
and you're damned if you don't.
What do you do as a consequence of
facing that challenge?
And so you remember with the great
mother with chaos and the unknown,
the way you meet,
the challenges to understand that the
things you don't understand are
dangerous and frightening,
and that if you encounter them,
they can hurt you and that this is real,
but you don't run away all the same,
right?
If you're trying to get somewhere and
things you don't understand happen,
you can't shut yourself down.
You have to explore cautiously and try
to gain new knowledge.
How do you organize your social being?
Well,
let's make the presupposition that
you've got half a dozen or so
fundamental motivational states,
right?
So what they are is your subjugation to
a world of a priori.
Daddy's right?
You see in children rage,
fear,
hunger,
anger,
affiliation,
love the capacity to play all value
sets,
which have their own goal,
like behavioral patterns,
their own worldview,
their own way of manifesting themselves.
All those are innate,
right?
They're all dependent on prewired neural
architectural systems.
They have to unfold inexperienced,
but they're there,
okay?
And so let's say that's what you come
into the world with and that's what you
come into the world with and that's what
you come into the world with.
But then the fact that you're in the
world poses a more complex problem,
which is,
well yeah,
you've got one motivational state
happening,
you're angry,
but then you've got another one you have
to worry about,
which is you'd like to be affiliated
with someone like your sibling.
So you've got a real conflict with your
sibling.
It's like you really hate them,
but you really liked them too and you
want to play with them.
So what do you do about that?
Well,
you'd say a behaviorally dysregulated
child who isn't well socialized,
say they're impulsive,
they don't,
they don't act as if they take the
future into account.
So they heavily future discount.
They're impulsive.
What does that mean?
Do you watch a child have a temper
tantrum?
Which around too,
they're really prone to.
It's like it's a phenomenon.
You know,
it's like a tornado on a real small
scale in the child's just flipped out.
If you saw an adult do that,
you'd run away screaming,
right?
And they're completely dominated by this
emotional state.
And my sense watching that has always
been to kind of try to help the kid not
have that happen to them because it
looks like a terrible catastrophe for
their emerging eagle,
right?
I mean,
they're trying to get their world
together and something frustrates them
and womp up come these like a Mig delek
projections that are governing anger,
hypothalamic even more primitive and
just like bull them over and then
they're on the floor and they're holding
their breath and they're turning blue
and they're having a fit.
And then it takes him like 15 minutes to
recover.
So they have to take themselves into
account as total as complete beings.
And that's the emergence of a higher
order morality.
But it's more complicated than that
because not only do they have the
problem of themselves,
which is a bad enough problem,
but then they have the problem of the
other person.
So what's the proper response of the
individual given that he or she is
threatened by the natural world and the
unknown on the left hand and threatened
by the social order and it's tyranny on
the right hand,
but also dependent on the natural world
and chaos for all good things and all
new information and dependent on the
social order for their very motive being
caught between four paradox is all at
the same time.
How can that route b property
negotiated?
Well,
and then you can look at hero mythology
and the most tarman plot,
and I would say in some ways the only
plot,
although there are variations of this
that are endless romantic variations or
adventure story variations or variations
of failed heroic endeavor.
Still the only plot goes something like
this.
There's a current state of being now
that can be represented by a
psychological state,
your current personality,
it can be represented by your family.
It can be re represented by your
extended social group,
your city,
your town,
your country,
your ecosystem.
You're,
you're,
you're in science fiction frequently.
The entire global community,
right?
A structure is threatened by what?
Well,
you name it,
if it's dangerous,
it can threaten the structure.
Now it can be one of various forms of
barbarian,
right?
Any person from another culture and
alien in science fiction.
Uh,
a terrible monster that lives in the
deep that had been dominated and no
press before but has come back for more
an agent of horror.
That's a common theme in modern horror
movies,
right?
And object that moves the ghosts in the
basement because the dad were improperly
buried,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Anything uncanny,
anything fear,
inspiring,
anything Reptilian,
um,
anything that smothers or in trances or
seduces or you name it.
If it's change or some metaphoric
representation of anything that can
change,
then it's this the dragon of chaos.
And that's the thing that always
threatens the stable state.
And it's multiple potential manifest
forums.
And what does that mean?
It means the apocalypse is always
happening,
right?
The end of the world is always before
us,
which is why you see apocalyptic
imagery,
for example,
throughout the New Testament,
Christ says the world is coming to an
end and people are waiting around for it
to happen.
But what they don't precisely understand
is that the world is always coming to an
end always.
And that's because what you think now is
not good enough for the next second,
right?
You have to change because change is
coming.
And what change means is you have to let
go of what you know.
That's the apocalypse and it's always on
us.
The structure is threatened.
Well,
what do you do about that?
okay,
you can run,
but you can't hide,
right?
That's the theory.
And the reason for that is that even if
you are unwilling to face the threat
that's right in front of you,
no matter where you run to,
that threat is going to be there.
So you'll see in the case of an
agoraphobic woman who starts to run away
from the shopping mall when she has
heart palpitations that then she runs
away from the subway and then she runs
away from taxis and buses,
and then other people.
Then finally she's at home and there's
nowhere to run,
but her heart's palpitating.
And the fear of death is still honor and
there's no place to go.
So hiding isn't much of a help.
Or you can pretend that the chaotic
thing isn't there and refuse to change,
but all that does is make the threat
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger.
So just like simply put,
I'll say you only have $100 in the bank
and you have $110 telephone bill and you
think,
well,
I'd like that $100 I'm not going to pay
that telephone bill.
It's just a little threat,
right?
But then you don't pay it,
and the next month it's $125 telephone
bill and then they slap a $50 charge on
you and then they cut off your phone.
So then you don't have a phone.
Then you miss a job appointment and
that's not so good.
And then it's $250 to pay your phone
bill and another 200 to get it hooked
back up.
And then your credit record goes all to
hell because you haven't paid any of
that.
Then you can't buy a house when you're
25 and you think kind of weird.
A little bitty chaos turns into a great
big monster.
And partly that's because everything
that looks separate from everything else
isn't.
It just looks that way.
And when you ignore anything,
especially if it's impeding your
progress,
you know it's impeding your progress.
You know,
you have to deal with it,
step away from it and see what its true
nature really is.
So you can hide and you can not change.
Or You could pretend that the threat
doesn't exist.
But in the final analysis that just
stores up the catastrophe for later.